In 1999, 37 year old Bill Morgan was a truck
driver living in a travel trailer in Australia.
That’s when disaster struck- while working,
he got in a pretty bad accident that he nonetheless
survived.
However, medication he was given during his
recovery resulted in him having an extreme
allergic reaction that ultimately caused his
heart to stop.
After being clinically dead for fourteen minutes,
they were able to get his heart going again.
Sometimes with that span, the person may have
suffered brain damage and may even be essentially
a vegetable, though there are many factors
involved as to whether that will be the case
(more on this very soon in an upcoming article
from our resident writer who is also a paramedic).
In Morgan’s case, it at first looked like
that might have happened.
After they got his heart going again, he was
comatose and given how long he’d been clinically
dead for, it was recommended twice that life
support be removed and he be allowed to die.
Nonetheless, after 12 days, he miraculously
came out of his coma and was, shockingly,
completely fine, suffering no apparent brain
damage or other long term problems from the
event.
Not being interested in driving truck anymore,
he then found a different job and- as near
death experiences are wont to do, it made
him reevaluate his life, including within
a year making the decision to propose to Lisa
Wells, his long-time girlfriend.
She accepted.
No doubt feeling pretty lucky not only to
be alive, but to have his girlfriend agree
to marry him, he bought a scratch lottery
ticket.
The result?
He won a car worth about $17,000 Australian
(today about $23,903 US and $25,099 Australian).
Normally winning a car isn’t a big enough
story to get the media to pay attention to
you, but given that Morgan had recently been
clinically dead for 14 minutes, the local
Melbourne news decided to do a feature on
him.
In the process, they asked Morgan if he wouldn’t
mind buying another lotto ticket and then
scratching it off on camera for them, as a
sort of re-enactment of his winning scratch.
He happily obliged.
After scratching the ticket on camera, though,
he stopped, looked at the camera, and rather
than be excited and saying something like
“I just won a car” as part of the reenactment,
he instead said “I just won $250,000.
I’m not joking!”
This was the jackpot for that particular scratch
lotto he was playing (today about $369,102
Australian or $351,526 US ).
Needless to say, the reporters on scene got
more than they bargained for during the reenactment,
as did Morgan, who immediately called his
fiancée to tell her the good news about his
win and that they would now be able to get
a house.